Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Was ist los in Russland vor der WM 2018? Darüber haben wir schon mehrfach hier im Kurzpass gesprochen. Immer mit der in Moskau lebenden Journalistin Katrin Scheib. Und das tun wir auch heute. Ich freu mich schon drauf. Katrin, sei mir gegrüßt. Grüße nach Russland. Sehr schön, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit genommen hast, für uns ein kleines Update aus dem, Tja, WM-Gastgeberland zu geben. Und das, obwohl du inzwischen ja viel beschäftigt bist durch deine tägliche NTV-Kolumne.
Ach ja, aber weißt du, das ist ja ein Kompliment, was man gut auch mal dir in deinem eigenen Podcast machen kann. Das ist halt auch immer nett und mit dir so ein bisschen in die Tiefe zu gehen, ein bisschen hintergründiger zu erzählen. Das macht ja auch Spaß. Dafür dann gerne auch Samstagsmorgen.
Womit geleakt wäre, dass das eine der seltenen Folgen ist, die ich Zeit versetzt veröffentliche. Aber, na, das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm. Ich glaube, die Hörerinnen und Hörer können damit umgehen, vor allem alle, die auf Instagram dem Rasenfunk folgen, die haben es sowieso schon erfahren. Da habe ich natürlich das schon rausgelassen. Da darf man ja hinter die Kulissen gucken. Aber wir wollen ja nicht über den Rasenfunk bei Instagram reden, das wäre auch etwas Kürzeres als der Kurzpass, sondern über die Stimmung im Land vor der WM 2018. Und wir haben in einer der letzten Folgen, habe ich dir die Frage gestellt, wie ist es eigentlich als schwuler Fan, wenn man sich in Russland aufhält? Welche Gedanken geschießen einem durch den Kopf? Und ist es ratsam, die WM zu besuchen? Und du hast es tollerweise zum Anlass genommen, mal ein bisschen herumzufragen. Und das in einer deiner Kolumnen zu verarbeiten. Wie ist denn das, was du da so erfahren hast?
Ja, da muss ich eigentlich Danke sagen, dass du mich auf die Idee gebracht hast. Weil halt in der Situation, also natürlich kann ich dazu grob was sagen, aber eigentlich ist das ja schief. Warum soll ich als Hethe dazu was sagen, wenn es genug Leute gibt, die mir das genauer erzählen können, die halt wirklich in der Situation sind, als jemand, der schwul oder lesbisch oder bi ist, hier in Moskau in dem Fall zu leben. Das heißt, ich habe mich im Freundeskreis ein bisschen umgehört, bei russischen Freunden, bei internationalen Freunden, die hier schon länger leben, die zum Teil eben einen russischen Partner, eine russische Ehefrau und so weiter haben. Und die haben netterweise sich alle die Zeit genommen, die sie zum Teil auch noch zu weiteren Bekannten vermittelt, sodass dann eben so eine Mischung an Stimmen zusammengekommen ist. Es ist ein klassischer Fall von It's complicated. Natürlich ist das hier ein Land, wo dir Homophobie ständig begegnet oder begegnen kann, wo du im Zweifel, das hat auch eine Gesprächspartnerin angesprochen, auch nicht weißt, wenn jetzt jemand mir was will, ist denn die Polizei dann auf meiner Seite, kann ich mich darauf verlassen? Oder ist dann das große Weggucken oder stilles Unterstützen? Und da gab es ganz unterschiedliche Meinungen, von sehr restriktiven, kleide dich nicht so auffällig, natürlich auf der Straße auf keinen Fall, Händchen halten, sich küssen, so was. Bis hin zu Leuten, die gesagt haben, ich fühle mich hier in Russland sicherer, als ich mich zum Teil in europäischen Städten fühle und habe noch nie Probleme hier gehabt wegen meiner Orientierung. Das war ein ziemliches Spektrum, das fand ich auch ganz bemerkenswert. Was es dann am Ende natürlich wieder schwerer macht, zu sagen, soll ich jetzt hier hinkommen zum Turnier oder nicht? Kann ich mich hier sicher fühlen oder nicht? Man kann das nicht endgültig beantworten. Aber vielleicht, ich finde mal, es kam ganz gut raus, dass auch die Leute, die da geantwortet haben, unterschiedliche Naturelle haben zwischen Optimismus und Pessimismus und eher die Idee herausgehen, ausprobieren oder die Idee, lieber auf Sicherheit. Und dann kann vielleicht jemand, der vor der Entscheidung noch steht, hier hinzureisen, auch so ein bisschen gucken, in wem er sich da am ehesten wiederfindet.
Ja, das finde ich eine gute Orientierung, genau. Und es sollte einem im jeden Fall klar sein, es ist eine besondere Situation in Russland. Und dann muss man vermutlich eine Abwägung für sich selbst treffen. Wie wichtig ist einem die Teilhabe an diesem Turnier? Und wie viel kann man dafür aushalten, auch wenn es so ein bisschen im Unklaren ist, wie genau sich das äußert. Aber dass man da nicht einfach ohne Kommentare und ohne, dass das für irgendwelche Reaktionen der Umwelt sorgen würde, hinreisen kann, das ist ja auch in westlichen Ländern nicht so. Also müssen wir jetzt ja auch nicht so tun, als wäre hier in Deutschland zum Beispiel die heile Welt in der Sache. Das ist ja auch bei weitem nicht so.
Das sind natürlich andere Klimater. Also so ein Gesetz, wie das gegen sogenannte homosexuelle Propaganda, man muss ja immer da große Anführungsstriche mitsprechen, weil ja schon dieser Begriff Propaganda ein Kampfbegriff ist. Natürlich schafft das ein Klima im Land. Natürlich gibt es, ich habe jetzt die Woche noch eine Umfrage gesehen, die Zahl der, die haben Fußballfans gefragt in den Gastgeberstätten, wie sie zu schul- und lesbischen Fans stehen. Und die größte Gruppe, ich glaube knapp über 50% hat gesagt, das ist mir relativ egal. Aber du hast eben so eine Gruppe im Bereich 10-12%, die sagt, das geht so nicht, das ärgert mich, das macht mich wütend. Und ja, die muss klar sein, du musst halt auch für die Eventualität planen, dass du aus dieser Gruppe gerätst.
Ich werde den Text verlinken und dann können alle, die sich dafür interessieren, noch einmal die Protokolle genau durchlesen. Auch ansonsten habe ich sehr, sehr viel durch deine NTV-Kolumne und ja auch dein Newsletter, den Russball, den man unter katrinscheib.de abonnieren kann.
kscheib.de?
kscheib.de, ich habe noch gerade danach gedacht. Ich war mir nicht sicher. Ja, es soll schon alles hier seine Korrektheit haben. Also kscheib.de, da kann man sich auch den Newsletter abonnieren. Ich habe sehr, sehr viel gelernt schon über Russland. Unter anderem, dass wenn ich jetzt feststellen sollte, als Fan, der dort hinreisen möchte, und alle Hotels sind schon ausgebucht, dass es gar nicht so einfach sein kann, sich dann zum Beispiel via Airbnb oder anders eine Unterkunft zu organisieren, denn da hängt noch so etwas wie eine Registrierung dran.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen tricky. Und da musst du einfach schauen, an wen du gerätst, wen du als Vermieter hast, und zwar also Registrierung. Weiß ich nicht, wer vielleicht ein bisschen älter ist und als Kind oder als Jugendlicher vielleicht mal in der DDR war, der wird sich erinnern, da gab es dieses Prinzip auch. Du musst dich halt bei der örtlichen Polizei melden, wenn du im Land bist als Ausländer. Und normalerweise ist die Frist dafür sieben Werktage. Das heißt, wenn ich hier irgendwie Besuch in Moskau habe, dann ist es oft ja sowieso ein langes Wochenende. Dann können die zwar privat bei uns wohnen, aber wir kommen nicht in die Verlegenheit, die registrieren zu müssen, weil selbst mit dem Wochenende an beiden Enden kannst du ja irgendwie neun Tage hier sein, ohne über sieben Werktage zu kommen. Aber diese Regel gibt es und die wird während der WM auf einen Tag runtergesetzt an den Austragungsorten. Das war schon während des Confed-Cups so. Und was daran tricky ist, es ist ein bisschen unklar, was passiert, wenn du das nicht tust. Wie das ja ein Grundprinzip hier ist, der Behörden, dass Sachen gerne unklar sind. Und wenn man dir was will, dann können sie einen Strick draus drehen. Aber vielleicht ist es auch komplett egal und keiner fragt. Und der Knackpunkt bei so einer Registrierung ist halt, wenn du im Hotel bist oder in einem Hostel, dann macht das der Betreiber für dich. Du gibst ihm deinen Pass, der macht ne Fotokopie, der meldet dich. Wenn du in einer Privatunterkunft bist, dann muss das der Vermieter mit dir machen. Und da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Sachen. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, ja, alles klar, habe ich auf dem Schirm, können wir zusammen machen oder ich zeige dir, wie es geht. Ich habe auch gehört, es soll während der WM dazu eine App geben. Mal schauen. Und es gibt Leute, die sagen, Registrierung, sowas gibt es überhaupt nicht, völlige Fehlinformation, was hat man ihnen denn da erzählt? Denen es also nur darum geht, die Miete einzustreichen und das Risiko bei dir zu belassen. Und zum Beispiel, mir ist in jetzt etwas mehr als vier Jahren Russland nie passiert, dass jemand meine Registrierung sehen wollte. Das ist aber natürlich ein komplett verzerrter Blick, weil ich irgendwie eine Frau bin, weiß, westlich aussehe. Und weil so Rasterfahndungen, willkürliche Kontrollen in der Metro kriegen, eben Leute ab, die vielleicht eher männlich, dunkelhäutig oder zentralasiatisch sind. Und wenn man nun beim Blick in den Spiegel denkt, sehe ich so aus, dass ich hier in Russland systematischen Rassismus zu spüren kriegen könnte, dann ist es schlau, im Zweifel die Registrierung in der Tasche zu haben.
Ja, alles gar nicht so einfach. Wie ist denn die Stimmung davon abgesehen im Land? Das ist ja jetzt der externe Blick auf, wie wird es wohl sein, wenn ich nach Russland komme. Wie ist denn gerade in Russland die Stimmung? Freut man sich darauf, viele Fußballfans begrüßen zu dürfen? Gibt es da schon erste Vorbereitung oder ist dafür das Turnier auch noch zu weit weg?
Ne, du kriegst zunehmend jetzt die Vorbereitung mit. Neulich habe ich zum ersten Mal, ich glaube wir haben uns ja schon mal unterhalten über Englischkenntnisse, dass das eine Baustelle ist und gerade im öffentlichen Nahverkehr, habe ich zum ersten Mal eins von diesen Kassenschaltern in der Metro gesehen, wo dann wirklich so ein, ich weiß nicht mehr wie es formuliert ist, ich glaube We Speak English oder so Kleber dran ist mit einer Fahne. Und habe dann die Frau auch auf Englisch angesprochen und das ging auch gut. Wir hatten vor zwei Wochen Freunde aus Deutschland zu Besuch. Dann habe ich dann auch mal ganz schamhaft den Besuch an der Metrokasse vorgeschickt, an so einen englischsprachigen Schalter zum Ticket kaufen. Das ging auch problemlos. Es ist immer noch diese etwas maulfaule Moskauer Art. Also du sagst guten Tag und da kommt im Zweifel keine Reaktion. Aber wenn du dann sagst, weiß ich nicht, ein Ticket für 30 Fahrten drauf oder so, dann bekommst du das jedenfalls. Das ist so vom Stil, es ist eher Berlin als Rheinland, aber es funktioniert jedenfalls. Du fängst halt an, im Straßenbild immer mehr zu sehen, dass dir irgendwelche Werbebanner auffallen oder so. Ich habe mich neulich mit ein paar Leuten getroffen aus dem Moskauer Schalke-Fanclub. Das war auch sehr cool. Das sind halt Leute, die sind Fußballfans, die haben Ahnung von Fußball. Die sind jetzt nicht die totalen, wie sagt man, die sehen das realistisch, was ihre eigene Mannschaft hier an Chancen hat. Aber die sagen eben auch, klar, es gibt so Sachen wie das FIFA-Ranking, es gibt das Abschneiden der russischen Mannschaft bei anderen großen Turnieren, aber es ist eben auch ein Heimspiel und da ist so viel anderes möglich. Da kann die Stimmung die Leute beflügeln, die Unterstützung durch die Fans. Ich habe eine Umfrage gesehen, 5% der Russen gehen davon aus, oder 4% glaube ich, dass sie Weltmeister werden. Also das ist jetzt kein blauäugiger Blick hier. Aber die Idee, dass da was geht und dass das eine besondere Situation ist, das hört man schon viel im Moment.
Ja, ich glaube, ich werde auch nach dem ersten WM-Gruppenspiel von Russland gegen Saudi-Arabien der Auftakt ins Turnier sein. Ich glaube, da sollten wir nochmal sprechen, Katrin, wenn du dann Zeit für mich findest.
Das Ölduell habe ich gehört zwischen den Ölförderländern.
Ja, Ölduell, sehr schön. Und was es neben der normalen etwas berliner Maulfauen Polizei und offiziellen Dienststellen geben wird, es wird eine Touristenpolizei geben. Was haben wir uns dadurch vorzustellen? Kommen die dann gucken, ob ich genügend Spaß habe? Oder kommen die, wenn ich zu viel Spaß habe?
Genau, wahrscheinlich haben die so eine Checkliste. Hatten sie heute schon Spaß, schon gelacht, wie was Mittagessen? Nee, die Idee ist, dass das Leute sind, die halt in einigen der größeren Austragungsorte unterwegs sind und Ansprechpartner für dich sind. Für ganz alltägliche Sachen. Das, was man sich nicht wünscht, weiß ich nicht. Man hat mir das Portemonnaie geklaut. Aber auch das, was ja ein kompletter Alltag ist, wie komme ich zu der und der Sehenswürdigkeit oder zurück zu meinem Hotel oder so. Ich hoffe sehr, dass das klappt. Die Idee ist nicht ganz neu. Das gab es hier vor ein paar Jahren, 2014 schon mal. Da war ich noch bei der Moscow Times. Und ich weiß, das war nicht so ganz ohne, da diese Leute zu finden, die dann angeblich Englisch und andere Fremdsprachen können oder dir sagen können, wo du jetzt eben, weiß ich nicht, den roten Platz oder so findest. Das hat damals eine Kollegin im Selbstversuch gemacht und ist da eher vor die Wand gelaufen. Das war nicht unfreundlich, aber es war auch keinerlei Hilfe. Und andererseits, vielleicht hat ja gerade die Erfahrung damals geholfen, das jetzt besser zu machen. Insofern, die Idee ist sicherlich eine gute, dass du da einen Ansprechkartner hast.
Und ich habe ja bei dir gelernt, Katrin, dass man eigentlich auch nur ein russisches Wort können muss, um durch die komplette WM zu kommen. Moschner.
Du hast aber sehr aufmerksam gelesen, Max.
Natürlich.
Dir war klar, dass das alles auch gefragt wird heute. Bei Moschner musste ich so dran denken, als wir noch klein waren, sind meine Eltern mit uns irgendwann in so eine Ausstellung gefahren, so eine Monet-Ausstellung in Belgien. Und ich hatte gerade französischen Unterricht. Mein Bruder ist ein paar Jahre jünger, der hatte garantiert keinen Französisch. Und irgendwann hörte ich, dass der überall durchging und sich so durchwurschtete. Und was hat er immer nur gesagt? Pardon, pardon, pardon, pardon. Er wusste auch nicht, was das hieß. Aber er hatte gehört, dass das alle sagen, wenn sie was wollen. Und so ein bisschen ist das mit Morschner auch so. Das ist grammatisch gar nicht so ohne. Das bedeutet so was wie, ist das erlaubt? Ist es zulässig? Darf man das? Aber es ist halt so eine totale Alltagsfloskel. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du und ich, weiß ich nicht, gleichzeitig auf eine Eingangstür zugehen, dann würde ich dir sagen, Morschner, und die die Tür aufhalten. Also, darf ich ihnen dann mal die Tür aufhalten. Oder ich sitze mit einer russischen Freundin irgendwo im Café und sie zeigt mir, hat auf dem Tisch zwei, drei Bücher liegen, die sie gekauft hat und ich will mir eins anschauen, dann greife ich mir das und sage, Morschner, und blätter da durch. Und das kannst du natürlich als höfliche Floskel, die für die Russen halt ein totaler Reflex ist oder auch Reflexe auslöst, hier gut verwenden. Weißt du, drei Leute stehen vor dir und du möchtest jetzt an dieser Haltestelle aus dem Bus raus und dann musst du zur Tür, dann sagst du, Morschner, und dann gehen die wahrscheinlich zur Seite.
Das ist ja, das ist fantastisch, hätte ich fast gesagt.
Seid denn deine Begeisterung für Sprache hat Dimensionen, die sich mir bis jetzt nicht erschlossen haben.
Ich hab gerne ein Text zu geben.
Ach toll, ja schau mal. Und wie kriegen wir jetzt den Bogen zu Pornos? Das ist die Frage. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass hier in Russland, wenn Leute mitkriegen, dass du aus Deutschland kommst, eine Reaktion, die du oft hörst, ist sowas wie, ja, ja, das ist fantastisch oder nur das ist fantastisch oder das ist fantastisch, Baby.
Also auch auf Deutsch, ne?
Auf Deutsch, genau, dass sie das dann eben sagen im deutschen Wortlaut. Und das fällt einem relativ früh auf und man weiß dann, also ich wusste jedenfalls nicht, woher das kommt. Du denkst ja dann, so weiß ich nicht, da haben die einen Satz aus ihrem Schuldeutschbuch aktiviert oder sowas, ne? Total nett, die Russen, die finden alles fantastisch und die machen sich die Mühe, für dich Deutsch zu sprechen, ist nur leider eher ein anzüglicher Spruch, weil dieser Satz es hier so in die Populärkultur geschafft hat, tatsächlich aus westlichen Pornos. Es gibt da unterschiedliche, ohne zu tief in die Materie eintauchen zu wollen, unterschiedliche Geschichten zur genauen Entstehung, ob das die Lederhosenfilme waren oder irgendwelche DDR-Filmchen, die jedenfalls offenbar in den 90ern, dann so perestroika Zeit, hier auf den Markt kamen, populär waren und da sich dann oft halt diese Phrase in entscheidenden Momenten widerfahren, das ist fantastisch. Und so, dass sich das, ich meine wir wissen alle, Sprachelernen funktioniert besonders gut, wenn man es gleichzeitig visualisiert oder was dazu hört.
Am lebenden Objekt.
Am lebenden Objekt und sei es auf einem Bildschirm vor dir. Und insofern hat sich das fantastisch hier gehalten. Es ist nur nicht ganz so harmlos, wie es klingt.
Ja, gut zu wissen vielleicht für alle, die vor Ort sind. Das ist keine schlechte Information. Und vielleicht auch ganz interessant an der Stelle mal zu sagen, wie eigentlich der russische Nationaltrainer die Chancen Deutschlands bei der WM so sieht. Da hast du mir noch ein kleines Anekdotchen im Vorbild.
Ja, nicht so fantastisch. Es war letzte Woche hier an der Deutschen Botschaft so eine Podiumsrunde zum Thema Russland vor der WM und so. Und da saß eben Chechessow, der russische Nationaltrainer, flankiert von Kakao auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite der sportliche Leiter von Lokomotiv Moskau. Das ist auch ein Deutscher, Erich Stoffelshausen. Und dann irgendwann nach ein paar anderen Fragen haben sie eben den russischen Trainer gefragt, wer denn seiner Meinung nach Weltmeister wird. Und er hat gesagt, er möchte das nicht beantworten, weil ja jetzt auf seinen beiden Seiten Deutsche sitzen. Da muss man keinen großen Subtext lesen können. Das heißt also Deutschland schon mal nicht. Ich möchte aber nicht so unhöflich sein, es vor den anwesenden Deutschen zu sagen.
Ja okay, aber das wird Deutschland aushalten können. Und es gibt ja auch hervorragende andere Mannschaften. Ich stecke schon mit einem halben Auge in der WM-Vorbereitung. Und es ist unglaublich, wie gut manche Nationen aufgestellt sind. Ach, das wird eine... Also jetzt ist Frankreich schon sehr weit vorne. Ich fand, dass Frankreich einfach einen unglaublich guten Kader. Und wenn ich es gerade richtig in meinem Kopf habe, dann ist auch der Turnierbaum halbwegs dankbar. Brasilien... Ich finde, die haben einen sehr guten Eindruck gemacht im Testspiel gegen Deutschland. Und ich habe gerade vergessen, gegen wen sie davor gespielt haben. Das war nicht ganz so überzeugend. Aber die haben das gemacht, was 2014 gefehlt hat, nämlich auch nach hinten gearbeitet. Wenn Marcelo damals nicht wie ein Dover nach vorne gerannt wäre beim 7 zu 1 gegen Deutschland, dann hätte Deutschland nicht über diese Seite drei der ersten fünf Tore eröffnet. Philipp Lahm ist immer mitgerückt. Und sobald Deutschland den Ball hatte, ist Philipp Lahm vorgegangen. Und zwar auch wirklich aggressiv nach vorne. Marcelo hat es nicht hingekriegt. Und sowas, glaube ich, wird Brasilien nicht wieder passieren bei dieser WM. Deswegen sind die auch nicht so schlecht. Aber was Frankreich da auf den Platz bringt, das ist schon richtig stark. Und ich überlege jetzt schon tatsächlich seit Wochen, wo ich eigentlich England reinsortieren möchte. Denn da hat man diesen Klassiker, den man früher bei Spanien auch hatte, dass man sagt, hochtalentierter Kader, alles gar nicht so schlecht, aber aus der Vergangenheit heraus traue ich denen nichts zu.
Dazu habe ich eine zauberhafte Anekdote, die ich ein wenig anonymisieren muss. Sagen wir mal, ein Freund, der bei einem großen Medium für die Sportberichterstattung, Fußballberichterstattung mit zuständig ist, hat erzählt von deren interner Planung für die WM, wen sie wohin schicken, wer an welchen Standort geht, wer welche Mannschaft betreut usw. Die haben einen Kollegen im Team, der aus Orga-Gründen nicht die komplette WM-Zeit mitnehmen kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob er danach einen Urlaub hat oder einen Termin. Jedenfalls, der kann nur die ersten zwei Wochen. Und was haben sie in der Redaktion entschieden? Ist ja kein Problem, dem geben wir dann die englische Mannschaft.
Mal gucken, ob das so gut geht. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, welcher Reporter das war. Es könnte sogar Bela Reti gewesen sein, der aus dem gleichen Grund damals Rehagel zugeteilt war bei der Europameisterschaft 2004 in Griechenland, weil die ein besonderes Verhältnis hatten. Und da war auch der Plan, Bela Reti wollte ein bisschen Urlaub machen. Und dann hieß es halt, du hast ja auch ein super Verhältnis zu Otto Rehagel, dann begleitest du doch die griechische Mannschaft 2004. Und ja, wie alle wissen, das hat dann doch noch eine Weile gedauert. Ja, wenn es mal wieder länger dauert.
Aber was du sagst, mit Spanien ist ja auch interessant. Ich war vor ein paar Wochen hier an einer russischen Schule in so einer Klasse, die an so einem speziellen Projekt mitmacht, wo die über Fußball Deutsch lernen. Und habe die auch am Ende gefragt, was sie glauben, wer Weltmeister wird. Und darum haben die meisten Spanien gesagt.
Ja, stimmt. Spanien habe ich jetzt in meiner Aufzählung noch vergessen. Die haben natürlich auch einen sehr, sehr starken Eindruck gemacht. Das waren die schönsten 45 Minuten Fußball, Katrin, die ich in diesem Fußballjahr gesehen habe. Diese erste Halbzeit gegen Spanien. Nicht nur im Guten, da sah Deutschland nicht immer gut aus, aber es war so schön, es war, als würde man auf eine offene Wunde ein Kühlpad legen. Ja, da ist mir klar geworden.
Du bist ja ein Dichter.
Ja, manchmal schon. Vielleicht kommt das auch unter dem Eindruck, weil diese Wunde unter der zweiten Halbzeit, Borussia Mönchengladbach gegen VfL Wolfsburg gestern Abend, wieder ein bisschen zu flüssen wurde. Es ist alles nicht so einfach.
Ich bin ja Schalker, ich weiß, wie schmerzig es aktuell anfühlt.
Ja, wobei, das ist jetzt natürlich Schmerz auf einem Niveau, was schon lange nicht mehr hatte. Da kann man ja nichts sagen. Aber lass mal zurückkommen auf die WM. Ich habe eine Information gefunden, wie viele der Tickets bisher an welche Länder gegangen sind. Da liegt, 1,7 Millionen Tickets wurden bisher verkauft. Entschuldigung, 2,1 Millionen sogar. 1,7 Millionen im September, 400.000 jetzt im März. Und es heißt, dass davon die überwiegende Mehrzahl, klar, an russische Fans gegangen sei, 800.000 Tickets. Und dann lass mal durchgehen, wer jetzt auf den folgenden Plätzen kommt. Eins kann ich schon vorwegschicken. England sehr weit hinten, das hatte sich aber auch schon angedeutet. Die USA auf Platz zwei, Brasilien auf Platz drei, mit 80.000 und 66.000 und dann Kolumbien mit 60.000. Die Deutschen kommen dann dahinter. Das heißt, es deutet sich doch eine amerikanische, schrägstrich südamerikanische WM an.
Aber ich meine, Deutschland ist natürlich immer noch das stärkste europäische Kontingent, außer den Russen. Die USA finde ich total bemerkenswert, weil die sich einfach mal qualifiziert haben.
Es ist auch nicht so wirklich nachzuvollziehen, oder?
Nee, in der Tat. Also das finde ich schwer einzuschätzen, wie das so kommt. Ich habe auch letzte Woche noch was in der New York Times gelesen, wo verschiedene Tour-Anbieter gesagt haben, dass es schwierig ist, für sie im Moment Russland als Reisedestination zu verkaufen, wegen allen möglichen Gründen. Politische Lage, Tamtam mit Visum, dann die ganze Homophobie-Baustelle, über die wir am Anfang gesprochen haben. Insofern, diese 80.000, das ist mal ein Brett. Das wundert mich echt.
Ja, wer weiß, ob das dann auch alles USA-Fans sind. Das heißt ja erstmal nur, dass die Ticketkäufer in diesem Land leben. Ich fand es nämlich auch sehr interessant. Und dann natürlich eine große Südamerika-Fraktion. Also eben Brasilien, Kolumbien habe ich schon genannt. Dann kommt schon Mexiko, Argentinien, Peru, China. Die alle kommen noch bevor das nächste europäische Land kommt. Deutschland eben irgendwo in der Mitte mit 55.000. Glaubst du, die russische Mentalität kann mit der südamerikanischen, mit dem Frohsinn mithalten?
Ah, interessante Frage. Also ohne zu sehr in Klischees abzudriften. Ich habe selbst keine Südamerika-Erfahrung. Aber alles, was man so aus dem Fernsehen kennt, von WM in Brasilien oder so von anderen Tournieren, ist ja in der Tat, dass da ziemliche Energie investiert wird ins Feiern. Und ich glaube, das nehmen die Russen aufrecht entgegen und gehen da gut mit. Also, dass man hier zu wenig Energie zum Feiern hätte, ist kein Problem, das die Russler ein bisschen verobachten könnten.
Und dann gehen wir wahrscheinlich aus der WM mit einem Kaipi-Rezept auf Wodka basierend raus.
Kaipi-Rozka gibt's schon, aber ja. Ja, und diese England-Zahl, was hast du gesagt, 31.000 oder was?
Ja, nach Deutschland das zweitgrößte europäische Land.
Ja, und natürlich trotzdem eine relativ kleine Hausnummer. Das ist so eine Mischung, ne, England. Ich hab gesehen, als die letzte Ticketverkaufsphase war, das Kaliningrad-Spiel war relativ gut verkauft von denen. Was ja einfach auch komfortabel und schneller zu erreichen ist und so. Also einen ganzen Tag näher. Die anderen Spiele waren so mittel. Das ist halt auch so eine komische Situation. Auch da wieder zum einen spielt das politische rein, zum anderen, du kannst über die deutsche Boulevardpresse denken, was du willst, aber das sind ja flauschige Kuscheltierchen im Vergleich zu dem, was man jeden Tag in der Sun und im Daily Mirror und im Express und so weiter lesen kann. Also natürlich ist da auch extrem viel Angstmache. Unsere tägliche Hooligan-Geschichte gibt uns heute. Wenn ich da nicht Hardcore-Fan bin, sondern mehr so Event-Reisender, dann würde ich mir auch überlegen, ob ich mir das gebe, wenn das der Tenor ist, den ich jeden Tag in meinem Medienmix, meinem vielleicht etwas fehlgeleitenden morgendlichen Medienmix entnehme.
Und wenn wir über England und Russland sprechen, dann haben wir jetzt ja auch einen aktuellen Fall in der Politik, den versuchten Giftanschlag oder Chemiewaffenanschlag auf, sage ich, Skripal. Glaubst du denn, dass diese politischen Themen, die wir haben, also ich will jetzt nicht mit dir diskutieren, wer war es, das halte ich für einigermaßen schwierig, aber wir sehen ja schon, dass da eine Verschärfung des Thons auf politischer Ebene stattfindet zwischen Russland und anderen Nationen. Jetzt in dem Fall eben mit England, da hat sich dann auch Deutschland gleich an die Seite Englands gestellt. Und gleichzeitig wissen wir ja auch, haben wir vorhin auch schon ganz kurz angerissen, zwischen den USA und Russland, ja, vielleicht sehr, sehr enge Freundschaft, vielleicht aber auch gar nicht so sehr. Und auf dem gemeinsamen Schauplatz Syrien kommt man auch politisch sich immer wieder ins Gehege, um es jetzt mal so ganz wertneutral zu formulieren. Glaubst du, man wird sich in diesen vier Wochen Weltmeisterschaft von dieser politischen Dimension lösen können?
Also du hast ja immer diesen Split zwischen der politischen Situation und dem, was im Alltag passiert. Und ich bin da auch immer hin und her gerissen, auch bei den ganzen Boykott-Debatten. Was bringt es? Was ist konstruktiv? Also was verändert einen Boykott? Andererseits, was ist die Alternative? Ist es dann nicht stillschweigend, das mitmachen und mittragen? Und das ist heikel und ich habe da keine kluge Antwort drauf. Ich glaube, da habe ich tatsächlich auch mit diesen Schalke-Fans drüber gesprochen. Ich glaube, dass hier so im Alltag der Anspruch, Gastfreundschaft zu zeigen, sich als guter Gastgeber, als gute Gastgebernation zu präsentieren, den Leuten sehr viel wichtiger ist, als dieses politische Klima nun eins zu eins abzubilden. Wie das ja oft so ist, dass selbst in hohen Zeiten des Kalten Krieges ist ja oft Sport sowas, wo Annäherung dann manchmal noch ging, am Rande von irgendwelchen Länderspielen oder dass erst eine Fußballmannschaft geschickt wird und danach durfte dann mal ein Staatsoberhaupt kommen.
Unter anderem ja Deutschland damals, das Testspiel gegen die UDSSR. Das gilt immer noch als einer der Wegbereiter für die Reise, ich glaube, jetzt bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, Willi Brandt nach Russland, der dann die letzten Kriegsgefangenen losgeeist hat. Falsche Formulierungen, aber die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen, was sich damit gibt.
Genau, ich lese gerade so ein Buch über Lev Yashin. Und da ist das auch relativ interessant nochmal nachvollziehbar, wie eben Sport und gerade Fußball auch so als Mittel der Diplomatie eingesetzt wurde. Also jetzt historisch gerade zu kalter Kriegszeiten. Und ohne jetzt die Parallele zu ziehen und die Debatte auch zu machen, ob wir gerade einen zweiten kalten Krieg erleben, glaube ich, dass auch vielen Leuten hier, die eben keine Sportfunktionäre, keine Politiker sind, der Wert von so einem Alltagsaustausch total bewusst ist. Und wenn es nur ganz, ganz kleinteiliger Kontakt, ein bisschen wie ist dein Leben, wie ist mein Leben, wenn es nur das ausmacht, dass das, glaube ich, vielen Leuten ein Wert an sich ist. Das war ja, ich weiß nicht, ob du Alexander Gerst gesehen hast im Neo-Magazin. Der hat ja das Gleiche für die Wissenschaft so ein bisschen erzählt, oder gerade für die Raumfahrt. Selbst wenn es politisch hart auf hart geht, dass es wichtig ist, dass du so Bereiche hast, wo noch Kontakt, Austausch und so weiter stattfindet. Das habe ich zum Beispiel auch so tragisch fand, dass bei der letzten oder vorletzten Sanktionsrunde Russland unter anderem den British Council hier aus dem Land rausgeworfen hat. Das ist so ein bisschen das Gegenstück zum Goethe-Institut. Man sich denkt, was, wenn nicht einander gegenseitiges Verständnis dafür, wer wir so sind und wo wir kulturell herkommen und was für Menschen uns das macht. Was, wenn nicht das hilft, dass man irgendwann mal wieder konstruktiver zusammenarbeiten kann?
Ja, das ist eine sehr richtige Anmerkung. Vermutlich wird es so sein, wie es eigentlich immer bei Sportveranstaltungen ist. Es spielt am Anfang kurz eine Rolle, und zwar dann aber auch vor allem für die Medien, die nicht in dem eigentlichen Land sitzen. Die suchen auch noch auf eine andere Art und Weise nach Themen. Und dann wird es sehr, sehr schnell vergessen. Und für vier Wochen interessiert uns Politik eigentlich gar nicht. Könnte aber auch sein, dass in der Zeit durchaus ein paar wichtige Dinge entschieden werden. Und nach der WM geht es dann wieder weiter. Also man weiß ja inzwischen auch, dass der zeitliche Zusammenfall zwischen Sochi und manchen Dingen, die danach dann in der russischen Politik passiert sind, und auch was man jetzt in diesem Jahr gesehen hat mit den Winterspielen in Pyeongchang, wie das dann in dem Fall dann von Nordkorea instrumentalisiert wurde, ja, das ist, eigentlich ist es auch schon so ein bisschen gelernt. Aber wer weiß, vielleicht verändert ja dieses Turnier dahingehend auch was zum Guten. Ich habe neulich einen Bericht gesehen über die Winterspiele, die Russland nur für seine russischen Athleten ausgerichtet hat, wo sie die exakt gleichen Prämien bekommen haben, die sie auch bekommen hätten, wenn sie bei Olympia hätten antreten dürfen. Es ist einfach eine, ja, Russland ist eine Parallelwelt. Das ist so ein bisschen leichter hingesagt, aber ich glaube wirklich, weil das einfach so unerfassbar ist von hier aus, von Deutschland aus. Ich war noch nie in Russland. Und ich glaube, allein die Größe Russlands kann man eigentlich nicht erfassen. Denn das kann man sich nicht vorstellen, dass ein Land, dass das wirklich ein Land sein soll, dieses riesige Stück Fläche mit all seinen unterschiedlichen Kulturen.
Und siehst du, gerade darum glaube ich halt, dass es schon ein Wert an sich ist, wenn da mal Leute aus relativ vielen Ländern hier hinkommen. Es wird ihnen vielleicht ein bisschen leichter gemacht, weil sie statt Visum diese Fan-ID-Methode da machen können. Und klar, großes Datenschutz-Fass, da muss man nicht drüber reden, also haben wir sogar schon drüber geredet. Aber ein großes Problem im Verständnis von Russland ist halt auch, dass dieser Alltagsaustausch sehr viel weniger stattfindet als mit anderen europäischen Ländern. Und Russland ist eben zu einem Teil auch ein europäisches Land. Du erlebst hier Oppositionsproteste, wo Leute Slogans rufen, die rufen, Russland ist Europa, das ist vielen Leuten hier ein Anliegen. Auch was da ein Wertekanon dahinter steckt. Aber du hast eben diese Hürden mit Visum. Und du hast eben auch bei vielen Leuten dadurch eine verzerrte Vorstellung, was es heißt, hier zu leben. Also als wir hier relativ frisch hin waren, gerade so von den älteren Generationen, es gab Leute, die haben gefragt, wann dürft ihr denn zurück nach Deutschland? Und wir mussten erklären, nee, wir sind schweiblich hier. Das Land ist komplex und garantiert nicht unproblematisch und sicherlich keine lupenreine Demokratie, aber es ist trotzdem interessant, nicht nur als Journalist, sondern als Mensch hier zu leben. Aber den Schritt musst du halt auch erst mal machen, hier hinzukommen.
Ja, stimmt. Mir ist jetzt auch Siedenteils angefallen, ich war doch schon mal in Russland, auf Abschlussfahrt.
Das muss ja einen Eindruck hinterlassen haben.
Ja, das war Abschlussfahrt vom Abi. Also die Erinnerungen sind zum Teil bruchstückhaft. Und es war in St. Petersburg, was ich noch als, also ich empfand das damals als recht europäisch, wenn man zumindest sich auf den Hauptstraßen, in Anführungszeichen, bewegt, sobald man da an eine Seite, dass er geht. Das war, jetzt erfahren alle, wann ich Abi gemacht habe. Das war 2004.
Du, den Schmerz kann ich dir nehmen, indem ich mich datiere. Ich bin ja Abi 96 und war 97 zum ersten Mal in Russland, auch in Petersburg, mit dem Chor damals, auf Chorfahrt. Wir hatten da einen Partnerchor. Und das war auch, das war schon da, genau so. Also du begannst halt so ein bisschen zu verstehen, was hier dran ist, russisch oder posttaviertisch, was hier dran ist, europäischer Einfluss. Aber das, was wir so als westlich für uns definieren würden, das war halt auch, das reichte eben immer nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt. Wir haben im Hotel Moskva gewohnt, irgendwie zentraler Sowjetklotz. Und bis dritten Stock war renoviert, wir waren im vierten Stock. Und ich habe jeden Tag meine paar russisch-brocken verwenden können. Die Schlosseln in Yerebotnaya, das ist kaputt, das arbeitet nicht, das funktioniert nicht. Jeden Tag. Der Fernseher funktioniert nicht, das Türschloss funktioniert nicht, der Lift funktioniert nicht. Und das ist halt einfach ein verdammt langer Weg, der seit dem, seit 97, was sich seitdem in dem Land getan und verändert hat.
Ja, absolut. Meine bildhafteste Erinnerung noch neben, also vielen tollen kulturellen Sachen, die wir da gemacht haben, ich weiß noch, dass wir sogar eine alleinige Führung, unter anderem durchs Bernsteinzimmer bekommen haben, über besondere Wege. Also wir waren da ganz alleine mit so einer 12-Mann-Frau-Gruppe, unglaublich eigentlich im Nachhinein. Aber die lebhafteste Erinnerung, die ich auch noch jederzeit bei Mitschülerinnen und Mitschülern von damals hervorrufen kann, die mit dabei waren, war, als sich der Herbergsvater, wir waren eine Jugendherberge, da hieß es also um 10 Uhr müsst ihr alle rein und weh, ihr trinkt Alkohol. Und wir saßen alle auf der Straße und hatten uns logischerweise für einen Spottpreis Wodka gekauft. Und die betreuenden Lehrer waren mal lieber ums Eck in einer Kneipe und haben das alles nicht gesehen. Und dann kam um halb elf oder sowas kam der Herbergsvater runter und wir dachten uns, oh je, jetzt gibt es einen ganz schönen Einlauf, weil er hat schon so geguckt, als würde er uns alle Köpfe einbreißen wollen. Er wollte uns aber mit diesem Blick offenbar sagen, hier, ich habe euch auch noch einen Wodka mitgebracht und jetzt trinken wir alle zusammen ein. Und dann waren wir bis nachts um zwei und dann kamen irgendwann unsere Lehrer auch leicht schlagseitig angehaucht, würde ich sagen. Und waren dann doch etwas überrascht, dass sie da lautlärmende Abiturienten im Mitten des Herbergsvaters oder mit dem Herbergsvater in ihrer Mitte hatten. Das war irgendwie...
Schau mal, da hast du doch dann auch deine Frage zum Thema, können die Russen beim Feiern mit den Südamerikanern mitgehen?
Wir konnten damals nicht mit dem russischen Temperament mitgehen, um das so zu sagen. Der nächste Tag war eher zäh in vielerlei Hinsicht. Aber gut, jetzt bevor wir hier in meinen weiteren Anekdoten uns aufhalten, kommen wir mal zurück auf die WM. Wie schwer fällt es dir denn eigentlich noch, Themen zu finden für deine tägliche Kolumne? Das finde ich eine große Herausforderung.
Es geht. Also eigentlich wird es eher leichter, hier näher du an die WM kommst, weil natürlich jetzt du jeden Tag Sachen siehst, die sich tun, die du selber beobachtest, die du von Freunden hörst, die du in der Berichterstattung wieder findest. Ich finde, es ist eher einfacher geworden. So am Anfang, 100 Tage vorher, da konnte man grundsätzliche Sachen erzählen. Wie funktioniert Russland? Wie funktioniert Moskau? Aber nee, ich habe jetzt durchaus einen gut gefüllten Themenspicker für die nächsten Wochen. Es ist jetzt tatsächlich mehr so, dass ich überlege, welches Thema wann. Ich habe ganz am Anfang mal darüber geschrieben, welche Impfungen man braucht, wenn man nach Russland kommt, weil das einfach etwas ist, was du früh eintüten musst. Und jetzt will ich demnächst mal darüber schreiben, was gute Sprachlern-Apps sind. Das macht ja keinen Sinn, wenn du vier Monate vorher mit Sprachlernen anfängst. Das wird ja nicht dein Hauptlebensinhalt sein, dich hier auf Russland vorzubereiten, dass alles wieder verflogen, bis du reist. Aber so in den vier Wochen vorher, damit man eben außer Morschner vielleicht noch zwei, drei Appelbrüche zur Hand hat, das finde ich ganz sinnvoll. Oh, Max. Ich dachte, wir wären fertig mit unserer Aufzeichnung. Jetzt sagst du Nastrovje. Und jetzt muss ich dir erklären, dass das natürlich komplett falsch ist, es sei denn, du bist in Polen. Ich werde es dir jetzt noch erklären für deine Kajpiroschka, mit der du an einem stößt oder deinen nächsten Vodka. Das hat sich in Deutschland durchgesetzt und auch in den USA zum Beispiel. Der Irrglaube, dass man hier Nastrovje sagt. Und das sagt man nicht. Jedenfalls nicht beim Prosten. In Polen sagt man das, und das ist auch korrekt. Das kommt vielleicht drauf an, wie viel du konsumierst und was du dann auch unternimmst. Aber im Prinzip, russisches Prosten ist auf Sa. Also Sa auf und dann irgendwas. Und dann Sa auf die Freundschaft. Sa auf uns. Du fängst nicht mit Na an. Die einzige Situation, in der die Floskel angemessen ist und in die Verlegheit wirst du nicht kommen, ist, wenn du Gastgeber bist, russischer Gastgeber. Oder sagen wir mal, auch von mir aus Kellner. Und ich sag zu dir, oh, das war aber lecker. Oh, das sieht aber gut aus, was du mir hier hingestellt hast. Oh, ich bin schon so satt, weil es so gut schmeckt. Und dann sagt jemand, Nase da drauf. Und das heißt dann, tatsächlich, wohlbekommst, aber nur so im Sinne von, mögest du es bei Gesundheit zu dir nehmen. Das ist kein Satz, den du in einer Kneipe bitte von dir geben möchtest.
Katrin, ich habe den Eindruck, wir haben das aller, aller wichtigste, aller bisherigen WM-Kurzpässe jetzt gerade diese Sekunde erklärt. Und wie schön das eigentlich ist, dass man immer auf etwas trinkt. Das finde ich, das mag ich.
Das ist ein russisches Talent zu Trinksprüchen, weil diese kurzen, das findet natürlich statt, aber die haben hier einfach auch wunderschöne, lange, elaborierte, sentimentale, gerade wenn man sich ein bisschen enger kennt oder der Abend fortgeschritten ist. Ich war neulich auf einer Feier und das war eine sehr gemischte Gruppe, verschiedene Altersgruppen, verschiedene Hintergründe, verschiedene Nationalitäten und wir Internationalen, dann so Prost und Cheers und einer von den Russen sagte ja, also wenn man im Park spazieren geht oder in einem Garten, das schönste, was man da sieht, sind ja eigentlich immer die Blumen. Und so richtig toll ist das ja nicht, wenn man von einer Sorte Blumen ganz viele sieht, sondern wenn die Blumen alle unterschiedlich sind, große und kleine und rote und gelbe und lilan und Blumen, die gerade aufblühen und Blumen, die schon voll in der Pracht stehen und Blumen, die langsam verwelken. Und mit euch diesen Abend zu verbringen, das ist wie ein Tag im schönsten Garten und das ist nur deshalb so schön, weil wir alle so unterschiedlich sind.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, das ist ein wunderbar schöner poetischer Abschluss für diesen WM-Kurzpass, liebe Katrin. Danke dir, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, wenn du magst.
Ja, fand ich auch. Wir wiederholen das wieder. Das war Katrin Scheib, eine in Moskau lebende Journalistin, die eine wunderbare tägliche WM-Kolumne schreibt. Bei Twitter heißt sie EdKascheib. Folgt ihr da, dann verpasst ihr nämlich auch nichts. Und abonniert auch gerne den Newsletter. Danke dir, liebe Katrin. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören. Ihr könnt jetzt auch gerne die WM-Kurzpässe, die wir schon aufgezeichnet haben, nachhören. Und freut euch auf die WM. Es wird täglich was vom Rasenfunk geben. Ach, das wird schön. Bis dahin, macht's gut, meine lieben Blümchen.